[Musique]
par les game of thrones d'accord mais je
vois pas pour comprendre et patrick
timsit roy williams à un sketch à nom
d'une guitare n'est pas inscrit dans
l'audio guide ses pas hypothétique la
guérilla
sinon c'est pas grave on passe à nicolas
berneau ils adorent à vis d'un super
facile soit pas salue enfin la raison
dans leurs pas nicolas bernot on a un
sketch prend la guitare groupe reed
loterie chanson un million de jeunes
j'ai mon pénis c'est si beau jeu veut le
préserver
quand je me balade en ville tout le
monde veut l'embrasser
vous pensez que c'est facile mais vous
vous méprenez les gens sont trop tactile
ils veulent tous le sujet j'ai longtemps
cherché
ce afin de protéger non prévus s'est
soudainement l'idée
m'est venu comme un écran
j'ai mis mon sexe ni son balcon succès à
nice 3 gbit/s excellent ami sans quoi je
me mêle sexe dans un tupperware il a mis
son sexe dans un tupperware
il a mis son sexe dans un tupperware il
a mis son sexe
il a disposé sans cesse soit en
plastique
[Musique]
imaginez pas pis dans ce petit récipient
c'est un réel supplice car mon chez brp
remet dedans
à nice j'ai concocté un risotto il m'en
restait pour le midi le récipient étant
déjà rempli j'ai dû refaire un
évidemment ce n'est pas très pratique
d'avoir son sexe concédant une boîte en
plastique je regrette cette décision
je vis mon sexe et a mis son âge et son
sexe et la mise en jeu des sectes il a
mis son coin il a mis son sexe dans un
tupperware
il a mis son sexe dans un tupperware il
a mis son sexe
il a disposé son sein il a disposé sont
saines
[Musique]
une boîte en plastique alors maintenant
rien non c'est pas possible je peux pas
valider ça je peux pas mettre ça sur
internet
par contre c'est trop tard c'est déjà
sur le site ça vous a plu
alors n'hésitez pas à glisser votre sexe
dans un tupperware les filles aussi vous
pouvez le faire
c'est un peu bizarre quoi qu'il en soit
abonné vous et cliquer en bas à droite
pour voir une vidéo géniale